how's it going everybody gets warned
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and of course everything relating
to the MCU and today we have some
awesome Black Widow news it's been a
while since we've had any news relating
to Black Widow since the release date
had to be pushed back unfortunately due
to the corona virus as sad as it is if
there wasn't any virus we would have
already seen Black Widow by now probably
a couple of times at least but to hold
us off until November today we have some
awesome news about Black Widow and
taskmasters identity now this has been a
pretty big question ever since we got
the first leaked photos for Black Widow
we have not seen who's under that mask
not a single photo leaked or regular
have been taken of taskmaster without
the mask and every single scene that we
see him in in the teaser trailer in the
final trailer
he has his mask on so we haven't known
who he was until now so first things
first if you are trying to avoid any and
all spoilers for Black Widow including
not knowing who the identity of
taskmaster is you should click away if
you don't care and you want to know who
he is let's get into it
be sure to subscribe to stay up to date
on all Marvel content and everything
going on in the MCU and so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an
exclusive Iron Man Funko pop it ends
this week so of course as the mystery
around just who taskmaster is got bigger
and bigger and people started to ask
more questions we all began to do a
little bit of research and began to
theorize of just who it could be and
there were many different theories like
perhaps could be Hawkeye afterall we do
see him coming out of that tank like
vehicle with a bow and arrow or maybe
it's the Winter Soldier some people said
that it could have even been Tony Stark
which is absolutely far-fetched but it
was said but the most likely choice was
that it was going to be oh t [ __ ] bundle
after all he appeared on stage at San
Diego comic-con with the rest of the
cast and crew and he's the only member
of the cast that we don't know which
character he's playing and Marvel has
been very secretive about who taskmaster
is but doesn't it seem a little bit
obvious well he did an Instagram live
session the other day and basically gave
it away however it may not be what you
think but on his Instagram live session
he basically came out and confirmed that
he is taskmaster
he was talking and he said that there's
also this conspiracy that I'm
ask master and then one of his friends
actually replied but you are and then he
said well well you just want to get me
in trouble with marvel don't you then
another person chimed in and said what's
up taskmaster in which he replied Oh
someone just said you shouldn't say that
Marvel is very strict with everything so
he pretty much did confirm that he's
taskmaster although this could be a
clever trick by Marvel let's be honest
we know that Marvel has a tendency to
mess with us just a little bit giving us
famous trailer scenes that are edited
that aren't even really in the movie of
course that Avengers infinity war scene
with the Avengers and the Hulk running
in Wakanda being the biggest one they've
done so far point being they kind of
like to trick us and for good reason
which we truly do enjoy so everything is
not spoiled so this seems a little too
upfront but here's the reality of
everything odds are he probably is
taskmaster but there's going to be a
bigger twist to this it's a movie about
spies and assassins there's no way it's
going to be this easy to figure out
ot [ __ ] bundle as taskmaster Screen Rant
has revealed that his character is going
to be Rick Mason and what Marvel seems
to be doing here is honoring the comic
book origin of taskmaster the
description that we have for the movie
of Rick Mason's character is very
similar to taskmasters origin taskmaster
spent some time working for the US
government in the aftermath of Civil War
opposing The Secret Avengers well we
know that Black Widow is going to take
place right after the events of the MCU
Civil War and meanwhile Rick Mason is
described as a former shield operative
which could give him a potential link to
the White House as you can see the
origin sound pretty similar now the big
twist is most likely and again spoiler
alert if you don't want to hear this
click away now but the big twist is most
likely that Mason is going to be some
type of lover of Natasha and former
shield colleague but we'll go on to be
revealed to be taskmaster in the
beginning of the movie they'll show us
ot [ __ ] bindle as Mason and from there
we're not going to think that he's
taskmaster but of course it will be
revealed at the end that he is this is
most likely what's going to happen in
fact this has been talked about in a few
leaks that we've gotten for the black
widow film there are definitely going to
be several twists in the movie and this
is just going to be one of them but ot
seemingly confirmed it and given the
fact that his character is pretty much
unknown right
it seems pretty obvious but let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below and let me know how
excited you are to finally see Black
Widow when it finally comes out in
November be sure to give the video a
like and subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU for live
updates you can always follow me on
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof